Library two weeks after the special
European Council will Mark the tragic
anniversity of this of the start of the
Russian war
the European Council is expected to
reaffirm the eu's Resolute determination
to support Ukraine and the Ukrainian
people for for as long as it takes
I know the parliament is steadfast in
its support Ukraine and I would like to
thank you all for this
regarding the economic agenda leaders
will discuss how EU can tackle challenge
in facing European Europe's economic
industrial and technological base in the
short term in doing so they will build
on today's contribution by the
commission on a green deal industrial
plan
among other things leaders are expected
to discuss possible temporary
adjustments on state aid policy and how
to streamline procedures while
preserving the Integrity of the single
Market
by the time of the meeting we will
probably have a deeper understanding of
the challenges for the European industry
as the commission is expected to prepare
the analysis analysis
but it is necessary to look at other
policy tools too much can be achieved by
improving the business environment and
by cutting red tape
we also need a fully developed and
integrated European Capital Market and a
bit and an ambitious robust and
sustainable trade agenda
in the long term it is crucial for the
EU to realize the full potential of this
single Market as it celebrate 30 years
at at the most European Council leaders
will discuss competitiveness and
increase productivity in the longer term
this is essential for EU to remain an
attractive place to invest for a
prosperity and for the role our role on
the world stage
migration will be another paid major
Topic at this meeting
leaders are expected to discuss ways in
which the EU can intensify its joint
actions such as strengthening control of
the eu's external borders including
through frontex support from member
states actions and the use of it tools
working with countries of the region and
Transit along all routes on Partnerships
to avoid further death encounter illegal
migration
and also issues of return and
readmission alignment with the esa the
EU Visa policy and the fight against
trafficking and smuggling as well as the
unacceptable use of migration for
political purposes
finally calling up finally calling up
the coal legislators to continue work on
the migration pact as foreseen in the
joint roadmap on Migrate migration and
Asylum thank you very much for your
attention I'm looking forward to hearing
your views
thank you very much Minister Roswell I
now give the flaws of the president of
the commission
to take the floor
thank you very much Madam president the
Alberta but a minister honorable members
last year frontex reported 330
000 irregular border crossings
this is a 64 percent increase compared
to the year before
and the highest figure since 2016.
in parallel
there were 924
000 Asylum applications across the
European Union
there are without any doubt increasing
pressures at our external borders
and it is our duty
to make sure that Europe continues to be
a space for protection for those who
need it
however the Asylum reception system
across member states are under
considerable strength and fact is that
the majority of those who apply for
Asylum are not in Need for protection
but return rates
are at a low of 22 percent
and there is an increasing number of
secondary movement
honorable members
migration
is a European challenge
which must be met with a European
response
this might sound like common sense
but it took us almost 10 years to
acknowledge this reality
at the European Council next week I will
propose to the heads of state and
government two separate work strands
the legislative process is one and the
operational actions we can take already
now is the second
on the legislative process
the best response we can give to is to
advance the new pact on migration and
Asylum
since the commission presented its
proposals we've seen quite some good
progress we have agreed on the EU blue
card to attract highly skilled Personnel
we have established a new EU Asylum
agency in December a political agreement
was reached on three important
legislative proposals
trilog started to upgrade our biometric
database the Euro deck and we hope for
trilogs to start soon on screening
so we must keep up the good pace
and hear the role of this house is key
I'm glad that on your initiative Madame
President Diego Roberta Parliament and
Council agreed on a road map
to conclude all the legislative work
before March next year and you can count
on the full support of the commission to
achieve that I know that vice president
Margarita skinas and commissioner
Johansson are working tirelessly on that
the second work strand is immediate
action
this is what the European Council will
focus on
over time we have developed a migration
and Border management toolbox we have
stronger agencies and we are better
coordinated
we have proven to be able to respond to
certain demands if we work together
take the instrumentalization of migrants
by Belarus
all of a sudden rise of irregular
migration in the western Balkans
or our response to Russia's brutal
aggression against Ukraine a whole
continent has mobilized for our
Ukrainian friends
volunteers rushed to the borders
families opened their homes and not only
their homes but also their hearts and at
the institutional level we immediately
activated temporary protection for
ukrainians
we know
that we can address increasing
challenges if we take action together
and now we can do this again
here I want to outline Four Points of
action where we can make a real
difference on the ground
the first is
we have a shared interest in strong
external borders
the most pressing issue right now are at
the land border between Bulgaria and
turkey
we can strengthen the border with
management capabilities
we can also provide infrastructure and
equipment like drones and radar and
other means of surveillance
as we've done last year for example in
the last years for example in Romania
we've done it in Spain and Greece and in
Poland
and we can increase the presence of
frontex
on the other hand
we must urgently address the situation
in the central Mediterranean
the migratory pressure has increased
significantly
and all too often tragically at the
expense of human life
we need to support our member states as
well as our North African partners
in coordinating their search and rescue
capacities
and we will continue supporting unhcr
and iom on the ground
to help build capacities for Asylum
reception and return
at the same time we will continue
supporting member states
to address challenges along the western
and Eastern Mediterranean roads
honorable members
behind all this
they are criminal Networks
they are organizing ruthlessly
the Chevy life vests the boats they're
robbing the migrants they're trading in
human life
we have to intensify our fight against
those Smugglers
and we will launch a new anti-smuggling
partnership with key third countries
this will bring together prosecutors and
law enforcement authorities supported by
europol and supported by Euro just
together we have to stop this business
of exploitation
my second point
is focusing on faster and dignified
returns
every year there are around three
hundred thousand thousand return
decisions taken by member states
only around 7 20 000 people are actually
returned
we have to get better
some of the shortcomings we can act on
now
for instance a return decision
that is taken in one member state
should be valid in all member states
so if a person with a return decision by
Italy is found in France
that person can be directly returned to
its country of origin
this will become possible now with the
Schengen information system that enters
into Force into operation in March and
we want member states to make use of
this possibility
thirdly we have to address secondary
movements while ensuring effective
solidarity
solidarity and responsibility are two
sides of the same coin
and therefore these two issues can only
be addressed together let me give you
some figures
and some elements that are important for
us we must work together to reduce the
incentives for secondary movements it is
very good that we have the Dublin
roadmap now since December in place
but member states of course need to
implement it now
and at the same time if we look at the
voluntary solidary mechanism agreed Last
Summer
this should not only be on paper it
needs to deliver
until today
there are only 8 000 pledges for
relocation
and just round about 400 have actually
been transferred
so European solidarity must and can be
stronger than that
and we will need to see to this with a
permanent solidarity mechanism in the
new pact on migration and Asylum
last but definitely not least
there is the external dimension
we need to engage more closely with key
partners
migration management must be built in as
one important aspect of the European
Union's relations with partners
overall our relations need to reflect
the Strategic engagement in a spirit of
cooperation
we should recognize the interests of our
partners and cooperate with them
by supporting education by creating new
businesses business opportunities by
fostering job creation
that same Spirit of cooperation
should help us to reduce irregular
departures and step up returns
Talent Partnerships Visa policy trade
and investment play an important role
here as well as opportunities for safe
and legal Pathways as part of our
overall comprehensive approach to
migration management it is a fair
balance that we need to find
honorable members
migration is very complex it's a matter
of understanding each other's challenges
and a matter of working together
this is what we will present to the
European Council on the 9th of February
on the completely different sheet of
paper
let me ask you for your kind
understanding
that I have to leave the plenary right
now because I am together with the
College of commissioner now on my way on
a mission to Ukraine where we want to go
together as a college of commissioner
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
to the president of the commission I now
give the representatives of the
political groups on the first round the
president of the Epp group Mumford Weber
president metzola the minister the
president of commission good luck in
Kiev and send good signals to our
friends their full support
so next well I think we should actually
be proud as Europeans if you look at the
major crises of the recent years the war
in the former Yugoslavia
800 000 refugees were welcomed the
Syrian War where a million uh refugees
were brought to Europe and then in the
Ukraine almost uh eight million people
are now on the run so we've seen in the
face of major crises Europe has shown
the will to help Asylum law is one of
the great achievements of the European
Union and that we should be very proud
of
we have been very successful and I would
like to expressly thank frontex and its
staff that do a good job every single
day they do their service and ensure
that European law is implemented at the
borders
well
it's been a long road but uh uh
resources are limited
in Belgium for example the reception
capacity is full citizens are losing
trust in our system and wondering if it
still works
I just wanted to mention a couple of
points on the basis of what uh Sullivan
de Langer said first of all we need to
secure Europe's external borders we need
to implement European law at the border
we need technical measures for that but
I wanted to tell the Epp group in
particular that walls and fences are not
a taboo
we've heard with some surprise that
these fences are not necessary but if
you look around Europe in Spain at
suitability
across Europe there are fences that are
exceptionally necessary so it has to be
possible to get financing for these from
the commission
and then we've got the issue of NGO
search and rescue boats in the
Mediterranean saving lives is a key
principle
Civil Society involvement is welcome in
the Mediterranean provided they are
helping people so it's right good and
welcome
but there are rules we need a common
understanding
that is shared by everyone who's active
in the Mediterranean there needs to be a
code of conduct as to how we deal with
the measures in the Mediterranean
not all uh refugees that are picked up
or migrants that are picked up in the
Mediterranean have to be brought
straight to Italy they can be taken
elsewhere as well
then we've got the issue of return
340 000 people who should be returning
uh after being having their claims
turned down after a legal uh
uh legal Asylum claim then they've been
turned out and very few are actually
turning back I heard it was 24
000 actually returned
we need to uh negotiate return
agreements with third countries to make
return possible but unfortunately in
this parliamentary term we haven't
managed to do to negotiate even one
single uh return agreement except for
Belarus strangely enough and that is the
only place where we can actually return
people to but of course people don't
particularly want to return there
so we do need to look at how we
negotiate these kind of agreements with
the third countries we need legal routes
into the EU there's no doubt about that
if you look at Syria if you go to the uh
the camps there I think it's only
correct that can Canada is opening
offices to relocate people well why
isn't Europe doing that why aren't we in
Egypt in Tunisia with offices on the
ground to try and offer people a legal
route into Europe why are we doing the
same thing as Canada
and our democratic government
in Denmark made this proposal of doing
this sort of thing outside Europe we
need to find legal routes for migrants
to enter Europe
so it's good that the special council
meeting is uh taking place it's good
that the heads of state and government
are dealing with it but seven years on
from the last major my group migration
crisis I think we need some Deeds Europe
helps but it also needs to implement the
law
but now I
are at gracias president thank you
president
[Music]
the uh uh large movements of humans Mark
our time we have uh hundreds of
thousands of internally displaced people
who've been forced to leave their homes
fleeing terrorism war or persecution
many of these people
risk their lives
at sea or on land on their Journey
towards Europe
they want to have
a dignified life we can't
allow the council to do nothing it has
to be clear that the European Union
commits to taking the new pact for
Asylum migration before the end of this
Parliament the Socialist and Democrats
party uh family wants to see a pact that
will have an obligatory uh
relocation article which make that I
mean that every member State takes their
um responsibility
now this alone can't solve the tragedy
that we're seeing in the Mediterranean
we need to have better coordination
between member states this is obligatory
for the commission however
we have to be able to adopt concrete
measures which will attack which will
tackle sorry uh NGO rescue boats for
example
we have to fight trafficking and provide
support for countries of origin and
countries of Transit but we also have to
provide International protection for
Asylum Seekers to support refugees and
to ensure that we encourage legal
migration routes having an educational
or humanitarian visas for example
uh we can't focus only on return Yes
there have been people who
uh have been expelled from the country
and people do have a right to return to
their country but to do this people need
to see an end to war put an end to
terrorism
criminalizing ngos and building walls
that uh
which is supported by the writing
extreme right can not uh solve our
problems
foreign
we have a cultural and religious
diversity this is an
um
a reality that we have to accept and
it's one that
is in line with the rights of the uh
host countries we have to change however
the ways that we
manage migration
migration can be seen as a solution to
our demographic problems and our
Workforce shortages in Europe
uh currently 70
of the population is of working age but
in the future this is going to drop to
54 uh Belgium the Netherlands and Czech
Republic uh they have very low um
percentages in France and Italy it's uh
12 and a half percent
um many member states have already
legislated to try to attract migrants
and we shouldn't forget this when we're
taking our decisions ladies and
gentlemen
sharing responsibility is the only way
to find solutions to these challenges
that affecting all of us no country can
solve these problems on their own
we can't
be Fortress Europe we have to be a
Europe of solidarity that's the only way
we can understand one another
Mr uh Weber was talking about walls and
fences we need to have an agreement even
um Madame Van Der Lyon didn't want to
make these references we want to focus
on solidarity we want to work towards
European values
we have a responsibility and we have to
work with generosity when we look
towards our future thank you on behalf
of the renew Europe group to Malik
azmazi
yes it's better
wow they are colleagues and their
presidents in a year European election
will determine the future of Europe and
what are the biggest concerns of our
voters well we know it certainly the
High Cost of Living the war in Ukraine
will assure you that also migration will
be on the top of their minds
we see this as a concern of many
citizens but I do not see the urgency to
deliver colleagues it's time to wake up
this mismatch between what we need to do
and what is being achieved is dangerous
first we need a real progress on the
Masala migration and Asylum pact
responsibility as solidarity must go
hand in hand and a third element to come
to an agreement is missing however and
that is trust trust between member
states and here lies also a rule for the
commission
the commission has to step up to break
the cycle of mistrust existing between
member states by enforcing also rules
also current rules
towards also the new package
W rules do not seem to exist now and
because of it trust has been eroding
from the moment commission have made its
proposals our focus should be on
concrete results for our citizens to
provide immediate relief to our external
borders and we must do everything in our
power to strike new agreements with food
countries to counter irregular migration
and increase returns including by using
our trade and fisa policy as a leverage
this should be a top priority for the
commission colleagues
then faced with a pandemic Europe
delivered then faced with war
we act quickly together
migration cannot be the Cinderella of EU
achievements this mandate instead of
rhetoric a fairy tales we need real
focus and concrete delivery it's time
for Action thank you
thank you I give the flow now to the
co-president of the green group Terrier
thank you
thank you chair commissioner Minister
colleagues ahead of the UCO next week we
are facing a crucial moment for the
future of our economy and our
competitiveness but let me be clear not
with senseless deregulation dismantling
workers rights or environmental
standards or this so-called moratorium
on regulation we can make the European
Union strong and competitive for the
21st century our competitiveness will
depend on how well we can lead the green
transformation globally supporting green
Industries being the first when it comes
to climate and environmentally friendly
Technologies and yes for that we will
actually need green and sustainable
regulation to give planning security to
our companies and yes for setting the
scene globally to move ahead with the
green transformation and indeed we will
need money for that we will not need
random investment but we will need very
targeted green invest Assessments in
order to make this possible
and I've read the letter that the
commission president sent to the member
states on migration and let me be honest
to me it sounded in a very technocratic
and de-politicized language it sounded
like a plan to create a fortress Europe
not once there was a mention of Human
Rights not once there was a mention of
the suffering of those who are trying to
find shelter in the European Union and
not once there was a mention of
international law international law that
bounced the European Union when it comes
to Asylum but also in the framing we are
talking about migration here migration
is not only about Asylum and returns
this whole initiative can only work if
we look at migration in its entirely I
negotiated recently a coalition
agreement between the conservative party
and the greens in Northern Westphalia
and I can tell you what the number one
concern of the smes of the Care Homes
and the citizens was it was the question
of how we can attract trained workers
trained labor in order to fit the
shortages in our labor market and if we
are not looking at this if we are not
looking what our citizens needs then we
are falling short of what we actually
need to address and don't get me wrong
we all want orderly border management we
want legal Provisions to be applied but
orderly border management Mr Viba also
applies to border guards and we have
seen in the past that there were illegal
pushbacks we have seen that this has
been covered up we have seen that there
was no punishment for this we have seen
that there was no accountability and
this colleagues is definitely
unacceptable the European Union received
the Nobel Peace Prize not for building
walls not in circulating this continent
in fences not for pushing back boats of
people who are looking for shelter we
received the Nobel Peace Prize because
this Union stands for a promise a
promise and for me the responsibility
and the duty that we have learned from
the horrors of the past from the
Nationalist devastations but also from
the suffering that this continent has
brought to the world a promise that we
will be a beacon of Human Rights and of
shared values and this commission
president does not end at how we behave
at our external borders thank you
I'll give the flow now to the president
of the ID group Marco
thank you president
foreign
ly the council is taking another look at
a very important issue at a fundamental
practice which the EU and its
institutions have been discussing for
years now without being able to actually
do anything to solve the problem
and we have High Hopes from the words
that we've heard today both from the
Swedish presidency
who have spoken very clearly about their
objectives in the first weeks of their
presidency as well as from what we've
heard from president Von de Lyon
who finally seems to have shown a light
on what the problem is and some
realistic solutions to solve the problem
of immigration
because if we just talk about
redistribution and open doors as we have
in recent years that means that we're
not really solving the problem
because redistribution with these
volumes is not something that anyone
wants the macaron government didn't want
to do it the Socialists in Spain and
other countries countries haven't wanted
to do this nor have others across Europe
so if we keep talking about sharing
responsibility without cutting the
numbers then it means we're not going to
solve the problem
uh previous speakers have already set
out the main points we have to focus on
external borders and protecting our
external borders
that's what uh developed countries do
that's what happens in countries where
the rule of law is in force and I think
the European Union should consider
itself amongst these states
I agree with something that we've heard
from my country and my party numerous
times in the past what we need is to
protect
it
Asylum Seekers outside of the EU
because the number of requests for
Asylum that is actually granted is
extremely low and so we should be
dealing with that outside of the EU and
we can do that because there's a lot of
money available we give loads of money
to uh third countries outside of our
external borders so perhaps we can have
some kind of agreement when we're giving
out this money we can ask for facilities
for processing Asylum quests
the European Union will take on the
responsibility uh ensure that they check
that there is respect for the human
rights of people who are coming through
these and then finally ngos
public authorities can't Outsource
control of their external borders to
private companies
because often we see that there is
potential law breaking here so we have
to reduce the number of people who set
off that will help us to reduce the
number of people who die at CM will help
us to have a more uh civil EU early
rumors
president metzola commissioner Han EU
Minister Roosevelt
soaring illegal migration
[Music]
an effective return rate of 24
of individuals who should not be on
European soil
unsustainable migrations migration
levels in Austria the Netherlands and
Belgium
these are among the main reasons why
migration is topping the European
Council agenda
Italian and Swedish voters also played a
role there I might add
last week e migration ministers declared
there is an urgent need to strengthen
the external borders increase returns
and prevent irregular migration
how the commission claims there isn't
money for walls in the EU budget
but there is taxpayers money to waste on
a 387
000 metaverse party that had less
attendance than a July after ski party
in Denmark
what about increasing Returns the
commission loves to dangle those
development Aid carrots
but it's afraid to stop funding
countries that refuse to take back their
own citizens
here's some advice
Finance border barriers see funding
countries who refuse returns and stop
talking about irregular migrations when
citizens hear you talk about illegal
migration that's when they will believe
you're sincere on Border Protection
thank you
I'll give the floor now to the core
president of the left group Mano Aubry
thank you president
prices are skyrocketing wages stagnating
life is ever tougher Europe is facing an
unprecedented social crisis and we're
seeing austerity rear its head at the
worst possible time and a horrendous
attack on our social systems in France
over 3 million protested yesterday
against pension changes but we're not
talking about that here today because
when everything is going pear-shaped we
always come back to the same old
scapegoat foreigners
once again we have a xenophobic
policy a supposed migrant threat Marco
zani is here on the red carpet
praising another debate on migration and
yet we're facing the most serious
inflationary crisis in history and
people struggling to make ends meet the
far right is proposing something
appalling that's nothing new but now
this has been taken on by the center
right Mr Weber and many liberals a few
years ago we all criticized Mr Trump's
dangerous
policies but now we seem to be signing
up for that same path Miss funder lion
is talking about
oh no not walls
but
those things that might be similar to
walls you'll understand their new ones
we already have a fortress in place
kilometers of walls and fences
migratory cages cages of migrants in
Bulgaria frontex daily infringing human
rights of Asylum Seekers
this is the truth that the commission
and some in this chamber would hide from
you
nothing from Mrs funderline about that
so let you me talk to you about accounts
from of migrants who have been
mistreated you can find these tales in
the Black Book of pushbacks our group
has edited this together with ngos
after beating us uh brutally for 30
minutes they took a break a smoking
break uh one officer crushed out his
cigarette on the head of my friend they
tore my dress and uh searched me uh
touching my body in front of my child
foreign
those
what about stories of those drowning
left to drown
all this has happened and you want to
see that policy become more widespread
Europe needs to respect its so-called
values we have said that time and again
let us ensure dignified reception for
Asylum Seekers thank you not to Laura
Ferrara on behalf of the nonetheless
members
foreign
[Applause]
should be an opportunity to say once
again that in Europe we don't need
barbed wire fences or financing to put
up new physical barriers between the
external and internal borders but we
needed solidarity and a fair share of
responsibilities as provided for in
article 80 on the Treaty of the function
of the European Union
to alleviate the disproportionate
burdens that fall on the countries in
the front line who are under the most
pressure what we need is an obligatory
solidarity mechanism based on relocation
uh between all member states we need to
cooperate with countries of origin and
of Transit and provide legal uh
access
to fight trafficking of human beings
um of migrants and to protect lives and
human and human rights we need to
strengthen agreements on um return and
reintegration and improve work
opportunities in third countries
after two years two years after the
presentation of the new pact on
migration and Asylum and after almost
seven years of previous proposals to
reform the system the European Union
can't waste any more time in finding a
new way to manage migrationary flows
what are the collages
good afternoon colleagues we'll continue
with the next speakers Mr angel
s
thank you very much president
Council commissioners
the truth is this
the issue of migration
is testing our democratic system and our
system of fundamental rights but the Epp
group
colleagues from the greens and the s d
we will not take lessons on fundamental
rights from anyone it's about dignified
treatment of people Christian Roots are
clear and present in all of our policies
the problem that we have before us is
how can we better protect human rights
of those people who are most vulnerable
and genuinely vulnerable are not the
rights of those who in many cases are
trying to Simply enter illegally and in
an irregular manner
we want better secured borders which we
probably control that would put us in a
much better position to protect the
rights of the most vulnerable to
organize legal migration for
good quality jobs that would help us to
deal with our demographic problems at
the same time we were to help the
countries of origin to develop
themselves and have lower migratory
flows this is a Humane policy that as a
policy is that respects fundamental
rights
[Applause]
thank you very much the next speaker is
Gabriella Bischoff one minute
yeah
thank you have father thank you the
president minister
disappointment and hope of closely
interlinked when it comes to migration
look back at the conference on the
future of Europe citizens were very
disappointed that Europe was not more
effective on migration many problems
arise because the EU is less than
effective here that is why it is
extremely important to recognize that we
can only make progress through European
Solutions the road map is important
Parliament has worked with five Council
presidences on a road map if I look
however at the pace of progress I do
wonder whether we can achieve the goals
set in the time remaining
look at the different issues screening
and the like people pick and choose but
this will all only work if we have a
package rooted in international rights
our values human rights now I come from
a city that knew a wall and building
walls that can never be part of the
solution thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much the next speaker is
Sophie Intel one minute 30. the chair uh
the debate on migration at the next
Council Summit is most necessary and not
a day too soon because after seven years
of complete stagnation on the Asylum and
migration package in the council it's
time for Action seven years Surplus
no Summit on massive illegal pushbacks
on thousands of deaths as a result no
Summit on dramatic reception conditions
their apple Brussels no Summit when
local communities became overburdened as
National governments are cutting budgets
for reception capacity or are busy
blaming migrants for the failure of
their own policies
government leaders have indeed agreed a
very timid voluntary relocation
mechanism but as President Van Der leyen
pointed out so far it has resulted in no
fewer than 8 000 pledges and 400 actual
relocations hardly impressive
we need effective and credible policies
but always in line with our values I
hear colleague Weber say yeah human
rights sure but
I say human rights full stop no buds
as to walls colleagues many have been
built throughout history none of them
were successful no it's a distraction
and not a solution as Mrs Bischoff also
said
Council and Parliament are currently
working in the spirit of good
cooperation following the joint roadmap
towards the common goal of adopting the
entire Asylum and migration package by
2024 at the latest and I therefore call
on the government leaders to not disrupt
or disrail the process but to throw
their weight behind the roadmap thank
you
[Applause]
thank you very much the next speaker is
Jordi Soleil one minute
we have had to tear down down many walls
both physical and psychological to make
the union that Europe is today it is
therefore regrettable that some member
states and some political families are
against again insisting upon building
new walls and fences and financing them
with you money to seal of Fortress
Europe they say walls will better help
stop migration
but what they will stop is our European
values we know how quickly they fade
away in outrageous episodes like the one
at the Melinda wall on the beaches of
Lesbos and in so many other places we
need safe and legal Pathways for
migrants amongst other reasons to ensure
that we tackle the demographic and labor
market challenges that we Face we need
to guarantee the right to Asylum for
those who need shelter so they are not
shamefully piled up in refugee camps or
illegally pushed back or drowned in the
Mediterranean Sea the far right and a
completion reaction to them must not
dictate the fundamentals of our common
migration and Asylum policy
[Applause]
one minute 30.
thank you very much president well years
pass and migratory pressure continues to
suffocate Europe in 2021 frotex
accounted 300 000 odd illegal Crossings
of the EU border these worrying figures
have to awaken the EU and
mean that we should face up to the
seriousness of the situation
we are being submerged with migrants at
this calls for strong measures but at
the same time commissioner Johnson
refuses oh Johansson sorry refuses to
erect fences and walls at the border
because uh she says that the EU has no
money to spare for that purpose but the
commission doesn't seem to care about
financial resources when it comes to
funding certain uh associations and
conferences on the future of Europe but
uh and uh people see the finance those
who supported wearing the Islamic Veil
so at the same time it seems that the
commission has a an agenda which is
pro-migration
people are talking about the
humanitarian corridors to encourage Mass
migration and there's talk of supposedly
qualified uh workers that are needed
well I think that this is just a pull
effect it's the job of the EU to control
the borders stop uh funding ngos that
are taxi drivers for the migrants don't
fund uh the illegal
associations and send back those who are
not uh considered worthy of Asylum it's
time for Europe to show firmness and
common sense because if Europe is not to
turn inwards it has to protect its own
citizens its companies and its interests
it seems that we're working from the
other way around and we will be opposed
to these new approach resolutely
thank you very much the next speaker is
aceto canco one minute thank you
president tomorrow we'll be voting on
lifting the immunity
of Nadine Morano in her home country
France she has been accused for daring
to say that rescuing illegal migrants in
the Mediterranean and then bringing them
to European soil is tantamount to
complicity in human smuggling I agree
with her and would even go one step
further if we allow this to happen we're
not only complicit but we ourselves are
engaging in human trafficking European
rescue boats that bring illegal migrants
to the EU are a continuation an
extension of uh Smuggler's rickety boats
last year almost 100 000 Asylum Seekers
arrived in the EU half more than in 2021
majority of them had no right to
International protection those are the
words of commissioner Johansson herself
this situation is not only unsustainable
it's inhuman Johansson said that our
duty to rescue people cannot be abused
that is true we are rescuing them we
should rescue them and bring them back
to where they departed not to the EU
that is how we will tackle illegal
migration we need to discourage illegal
migration not give human Smugglers any
opportunity to prosper that's how we
tackle this problem
thank you very much the next speaker is
one minute
after pool
what Mr Weber said
that the walls are not a taboo scared me
a bit
I never saw the Berlin Wall as a taboo
know the wall in Nicosia
so I think that his statement
was not a very good one he didn't take
into account history
the realistic and Humane facing of the
problem can be achieved at the European
level through legal and control and safe
routes four applications for Asylum with
mandatory and a proportional relocation
of the people in the member states I
agree with the Socialist we need
mandatory solidarity we shouldn't play
with solidarity European leadership
should stop financing and supporting the
causes creating refugees and the crisis
was the climate crisis and should
concentrate on Plants aiming for
prosperity and growth there at the
countries what is happening today is a
failed management we have created an
engine consuming billions of Euros Euros
belonging to the European citizens and
creates a new Dead ends oppression pain
and death and of course we have a simple
question
it was between Europe
and a candidate country such as turkey
is turkey a safe or not safe country we
shouldn't fool people and we shouldn't
play with the far right stories and
narratives thank you
thank you very much next speaker is King
the gal one minute
thank you president commissioner
honorable members the external borders
of the European Union are under pressure
and this migratory pressure is
increasing in the western Balkans
migration path there has been many
occasions of violence against border
guards the only solution is the
protection of the external borders and
stopping illegal migration this is why
it is not fortunate to to have
um
propositions which only want to manage
illegal migration instead of stopping it
solidarity based distribution of
migrants will only incite even more
migration and will only make criminal
organizations more complacent
member states
stop try to stop illegal Migration by
themselves Hungary
needs to protect its external borders
and it has been doing a lot to do that
but we have only been attacked by
Brussels for doing this for protecting
the external borders of the European
Union finally
the commission needs to finance what
Hungary is doing at its external borders
we need to
support
all those member states which are
protecting the external borders of the
entire Union for all our sakes thank you
thank you very much I'll now give the
floor to Jeron Lenas one minute it's
president 70 percent
tightly so 330 000 people illegally
crossed our borders last year this is
the highest number since 2016 and we are
sleepwalking into a new crisis literally
because our Dutch prime minister
Margaret admitted last week that he
dozed off on migration it's unacceptable
on behalf of the levels you refer to
Cinderella while the Dutch prime
minister really was more like Sleeping
Beauty European citizens deserve leaders
that are awake and that take their
concerns seriously and the upcoming
Summit is the opportunity to actually
show this to show the commitment the
commitment we need for real solutions
now we do not have the luxury to dismiss
practical Solutions just like that and
that is my question also to the European
commission president vonelain today here
underlined the importance to strengthen
our external borders and she mentioned
the Turkish Bulgarian border as a
priority but when Bulgaria then asks the
European Union for help to protect that
border to have permanent infrastructure
on that border they hear from
commissioner Johansson that they cannot
expect a single Euro Cent from the
European budget is that solidarity is
that the European response that the
commission is talking about I think the
Bulgarian and All European citizens
deserve an answer to that question thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much the next speaker is
caviar Bono Sanchez one minute
thank you president Minister
commissioner ladies and gentlemen
if we want to get Sustainable Solutions
via this Summit then we have to shift
the Paradigm as a dear Manfred we have
to change our paradigm
Solutions on uh migration can't just
focus on containing irregular migration
we have to ensure that we have legal
roots and that we can attract the
workforce that Europe needs we also need
humanitarian corridors for those people
who are fleeing war and poverty that's
the only way that will take control back
from the mafia and human traffickers and
finally putting
finally be able to create a shared
migration policy one based on respect
for human dignity and solidarity
and together in cooperation with third
countries and finally Minister I
understand
that in Sweden you may feel far from the
Atlantic or the Mediterranean
nonetheless we ask the presidency to ask
for the creation of a joint mechanism
for um Maritime rescue because otherwise
thousands of people are risking their
lives as they try to reach our coasts
thank you
with Obrigado
thank you very much next speaker is
Fabian caler one minute
thank you very much president
commissioner
minister
Jessica Crossfire
the only solution to the migration
challenge is the European Asylum and
migration pact no that's not a question
of walls Mr verba Epp colleagues it
doesn't mean examining Asylum claims far
from European territory that would not
live up to the humanist values that we
all share no it's we're together with
the far right that you are trying to
oppose an essential European agreement
moderate pro-european forces should
fight for a genuine Asylum and migration
pact a responsible Europe that
controlled its borders but respects
human rights we need a Europe that shows
solidarity that supports those countries
most exposed I think of Spain Italy and
Greece and Cyprus and in favor of a
Europe that has Asylum procedures that
respect human rights and are effective
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much I'll now give the
floor to Tom band and Richard one minute
honorable members
we are being overwhelmed through
undesired migration this is not a
natural disaster but the result of
deliberate political choices
we must protect European external
borders and send back irregular illegal
migrants rights are being abused to
allow illegal migration and creating
insecurity we are undermining the Asylum
rights for True uh Asylum claimants and
supporting trafficking and smuggling
models this is unsustainable and immoral
we must and can make different political
choices Asylum right does not mean a
right to remain reception must depend on
your own origin your country of origin
countries to do not accept returned
citizens have to be punished all
development Aid and other funding should
be ended
we need to ensure less migration not
more thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much the next speaker is
Veronica virtionova one minute
foreign
[Music]
thank you very much the European Council
at the upcoming Summit is going to deal
with legal migration last year it got
stronger
in the Czech Republic as well as in
Austria of Slovakia Hungary the number
of uh illegal migrants
has gone up by hundreds of percent the
Czech Republic reacted by increasing the
controls on the border and now these
controls are being canceled the European
uh the Czech presidency also managed to
unify Visa obligations with West both
Balkan countries which will limit the
number of migrants coming through this
route it is necessary to strengthen our
external borders and cooperate a bit the
countries of origin that means
strengthening our development support
and our cooperation in the area of
migration I also hope that the debate on
the quotas will come to an end we have
seen that countries that have protested
against this system now as a result of
the war in Ukraine have accepted a much
larger number of refugees than other
countries in the past thank you
thank you very much
million Africans by 2050 and 52 percent
of the young people want to come to
Europe
uh already over 7 million people have
applied for Asylum since 2014. that's
the same as uh the overall grown up
region in France or the whole of
Bulgaria every demonstration of weakness
on our part pressures them to try their
luck to leave their countries and their
roots to throw themselves into the
clutches of uh Smugglers uh and mafias
and go and die at sea for some of them
they know that if they reach us you will
take them in to make yourselves feel
better but in defiance of what our
people want you will be responsible for
destroying our civilization if we
welcome everyone from Africa and more
from Africa and the Middle East we're
not helping anyone we're just going to
become Africa and the Middle East
ourselves we need to have durable Human
Solutions and that's to deter them from
setting off prevent them from getting in
and to send them back if they do get
here we need to help to finance the
protections that have been put up by
Greece and Hungary and Bulgaria and our
external borders we have to sanction and
penalize um countries of departure that
don't cooperate with us and to encourage
those who manage to properly handle
their own migration without treating
them like children or imposing our
European ways we shouldn't share them
out amongst ourselves we should send
them home
sorry I think you have a blue card
do you want to answer
you have a blue card do you want to
answer
[Music]
is from
Janina or church
you've got a form
yes sir thank you
so as it was told
there is
last year there was 330
000 of people of migrants who entered to
Europe do you know what percentage is 30
uh 330
000 of migrants to the number of
inhabitants of European Union
foreign
you're only taking into account official
migration in France for example we have
400 000 legal entries per year if you've
taken um Miners and uh residency cards
uh and Asylum Seekers
and then we have the same thing
multiplied over all 27 countries and so
that's leading to millions and millions
of migrants who come either legally or
illegally but
they all want to stay very few are sent
home even when they uh come and adhere
illegally or their Asylum requests are
rejected so we need to put an end to
this it doesn't help the populations who
come largely from North Africa and
sub-Saharan Africa
um what we're doing is preventing those
countries from developing we want to see
Fair Humane responsible migration and
that means to do everything to help
people to stay in their countries of
origin rather than uh coming here
leading to both economic social and
security problems in Europe
okay let's continue with the comments uh
we'll have Mr troyo Alvarez one minute
thank you president
in 2022 over 300 000 people illegally
crossed the borders of the EU
there are thousands of Asylum
applications awaiting a decision
some 60 percent of returns decisions
from last year have not been enforced
thousands of people that should have
been returned to their countries of
origin and are yet still here people
such as the perpetrator who killed a
sacristan in Al jazeera's last week we
need to prevent any repetition of this
type of attack in any City around Europe
and so to this end Europe needs two
bolster protections on external external
borders and ensure that we have the
sufficient resources train our migratory
and Border Police
to this end Europe needs to Stand United
and act United migration cannot be the
responsibility of a few border countries
we need to strike the balance between
responsibility and solidarity thank you
thank you very much the next speaker is
Brando benefit one minute
thank you president
well I think that showing the shared
responsibility with the spirit of
solidarity that has to be the guiding
principle of all of the member states in
the EU in managing migration with a
sustainable approach for the future I'm
glad that the commission wants to make
progress on the on the Asylum and
migration pact and they want to get a
result before 2024. the Swedish
presidency of course has to deal with
this proposal but commission Mrs
Wonderland Charles Michelle it you
cannot simply see migration policy as a
bit having the objective of increasing
returns at the expense of the quality of
the European Asylum system the shocking
illegal putbacks pushbacks of people who
are escaping from war and poverty are
not acceptable our priority has to be
the revision of the Dublin regulation so
that the first uh reception should not
end up being at the expense of just a
few countries on the border but it
should be a common responsibility
this is just leading to more illegality
and more deaths at Sea that we now need
to have more shared responsibility and
we need clearer more Humane rules that
should not simply be vetoed and Council
thank you very much the next speaker is
young Christopher Georgian one minute
president thank you president honorable
members
I listened to Christian democrats here
in the room saying that we should make
Headway on the migration pact however I
have lost faith that they really do wish
to see that come to pass we have heard
appalling speeches from the far right
here in this house Epp colleagues do you
really want to go down that to
path and
betray yourselves like the French right
that chased after the far right we have
agreed on a road map working together to
make progress on migration pact show
compromise here don't be drawn by the
far right to try and pick up votes there
you won't succeed let's pull together
work together on a common European
system
honorable members if you want to see
fewer people drowning the Mediterranean
then don't
prevent ngos doing their work have some
sort of State search and rescue system
so that we can rescue these people that
see ladies and gentlemen we really need
to consider where we're heading we're
willing to work with you to strike
compromises to come up with robust
European Solutions but we're not going
to chase after you if you go looking for
the far right thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much Anders visterson one
minute
it's becoming tragic comic to follow
these debates year after year we
discussed the illegal migration to
Europe in 2016.
the EU clearly showed that it was not
able to deal with the seriousness of the
situations
ten thousands of illegal migrants
escaped all the way through Europe what
has happened since then hardly anything
last year more than 300 000 illegally
entered Europe more than half of those
who apply for Asylum are rejected but
they also know when they look at EU
statistics that the risk of being sent
home is very small
so unfortunately it is a big mistake
when we talk about European solutions to
the Asylum problem because the European
Union no longer works it would only work
to allow the member states to preserve
their National borders we should have a
pushback Model A solidaric model as we
know it from Australia let's not give
people the full solution that they can
come to Europe and settle down this only
helps the smuggling and crime that
results
thank you very much the next speaker is
Carlo for dancer one minute
Mr commissioner colleagues
we have high hopes for the next uh
meeting the extraordinary Council
and uh even uh Georgia Milani from Italy
will be dealing this with this topic
we've heard a lot of statements over
recent days and we think some are going
in the right direction uh we have to
look at the facts we need to get outside
of this failed logic of indiscriminate
redistribution of economic migrants
and this false distinction between
primary and secondary movements we have
to ensure that we are working with uh
countries of departure and Transit we
need a new policy towards Africa to deal
with illegal migration so we have to
strengthen our external borders we need
to have a proper a return policy
and to ensure that flag States and ngos
take their proper responsibility and
that we're only granting Asylum to
people who really are have a right to it
now is finally time to do what we should
be doing
[Applause]
the European Union accelerates the
digital identity trying to distinguish
between
immigrants the ones who can fit into the
capital system of the European Union
through agreements with
um with member states
while those that are not needed we want
to deport them
using the term return instead of
deportation and in bargaining with the
countries of origin in Greece
with one vote they promote agreements as
if the trading enslaved such as with
Bangladesh they defend by Rising walls
and using as police frontex in order to
prohibit secondary movements of the
immigrants and not implementing the
comments The Joint statement between
European union and turkey so the
migrants are trapped in the Greek
Islands and the middle class of the
turkey of turkey takes advantage of them
the services of asylum in in Turkey
are not
so finally we have to use a Humane
treatment and to process their
applications of migrants so they can go
to their real destinations the migrants
thank you very much the next speaker is
Thomas Tobey one minute
thank you
as that rightfully points out that it is
terrible that people are dying in the
Mediterranean Sea
but they are not willing to do anything
to go after the Smugglers they say
completely know that we should work with
third countries and try to have
cooperation I also listen to some
colleagues that say migration is a huge
problem for Europe but they are not
interested at all at delivering any
European Solutions
but I must say that I think it is
possible to build a political majority
in this house and also in the council
that could agree on that we need to have
control of the borders that we need to
decrease irregular migration that we
need to increase returns and yes also
that we need to offer protection to
people in Europe that has the right to
Asylum and that we need a stronger
solidarity between the member states
this is possible to do I wish the
council good luck on your next meeting
the most important thing you can do is
to get ready for trilogs because it's
time to deliver
Obrigado
thank you very much the next speaker is
Big at Sipple one minute
thank you
special summative migration in Asylum
the European Union loves to
Trumpets Devotion to democracy right to
Asylum human rights that is the Corner
Stone of all our values but
unfortunately
these values are not implemented in
practice in all cases and then we hear
some members of this house uh dredging
up old ideas Mr Weber talks about fences
and yet German history shows that fences
and walls are not the answer the
European Union is based on shared values
peace and the European Union cannot be
funding walls and fences
the strong European Union is talking
about
Outsourcing Asylum procedures to third
countries honorable members we need to
find a solution that strengthens our
shared values and respects a European
rights international law that is our
duty and I am willing to take up that
task thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much the next speaker is
one minute
thank you president
commissioner Minister ladies and
gentlemen
one should answer the following question
what migration policy is wanted by the
liberal leftist majority do you want a
policy which disregard EU regulations
whereby European external borders should
be secured that relevant regulations
specify who can and cannot cross
external borders of the Schengen Zone
that is the questions that we need
answered clearly because my impression
is that the liberal leftist majority
would like
anyone to be able to enter the EU anyway
and time they please I think the Asylum
policy should be a policy dedicated to
actual Asylum Seekers such Asylum
Seekers have been around in Poland ever
since their war broke out in Ukraine
after the 24th of February of last year
Poland saw an influx of 9 million
refugees War refugees
and what was the support we received in
Poland from the EU
while providing those for those refugees
well they blocked our access to
necessary funds from rrf that shows your
deep hypocrisy and your failure to
understand where really your problems
lie thank you
thank you very much
Johannesburg done one minute the
president
your excellencies Romania once the
European union to become a safer place
for its citizens but Romanians are also
European citizens they have an important
contribution to stopping illegal
migration in spite of that they were
offended on the 8th of December when
access was refused to Romania to the
Schengen area and this because of the
political cowardice of Chancellor
Austrian Chancellor neuhammer and he
paid the price for this his party had
the worst political score in the recent
elections in Austria dear colleagues the
European Union should not be a place
where powerful people decide on the fate
of millions of people what did Romanians
do in order to deserve such a Despicable
treatment they invested 1 billion euros
in securing the Frontiers they helped
3.5 million ukrainians they fed them
they gave them medication and they took
them into their houses because they do
not because they are Christians they do
not say they are Christians they really
are Christians Romanians are taking a
major risk in the vicinity of Ukraine
and we accept this risk and I'm telling
you something else Romanians are not the
suckers of the European Union I hope
that Sweden a country with a strong
democracy should reintroduce on the
agenda of the European council's shy
councils in March or in June which it
presides the expansion of the Schengen
area for Romania and Bulgaria thank you
thank you very much the next speaker is
thank you president Minister Sustainable
Solutions in the area of migration and
Asylum we already know what's not
sustainable that's mixing up refugees
and migrants and it's not sustainable to
identify as a legal laws who come in
illegally illegally
it's not sustainable to provide for work
for um illegal migrants when we have
millions of Europeans who don't have
work uh we can't it's not accept it's
not sustainable to have Moroccans who
should be sent home allowed to stay
the fact that we have um uh hundreds of
thousands of illegant uh migrants and
only 10 of those who should be going
home are in Spain we have over 30 000
illegal in over 7 000 are subject to
expulsion orders and we don't even know
how many have been implemented uh I want
to say to the families of those who have
been killed that uh we need to stop with
an end to open borders we need to
Europeans want their borders protected
we have to say this clearly
and people who uh fulfill uh legal
requirements may have a chance those who
don't uh meet the legal requirements
will not have any chance we have to
fight against uh mafias and to fight any
um disembarkment Platforms in um
neighboring countries and
our political group and it seems like
the Epp as well all agree on this thank
you
thank you very much I'll now give the
floor to Xavier Bellamy one minute
thank you president finally Council will
discuss migration issues vital for the
future of Europe and indeed over the
coming months 330 000 irregular uh
migrants crossing the border in 2022
we've seen this Skyrocket compared to
previous years some 1 million Asylum
Seekers have applied for asylum in
France alone let's be crystal clear
if we don't take action we will face the
consequences of these Rising numbers Ms
Aubry is talking about the using the
migration debate to hide social unease
in our country I'm always surprised that
the left do not recognize how hard this
hits those on low incomes in our
different countries this really shakes
up Society the commission needs to
recognize the scale of the crisis it
drags its heels and we need to be
crystal clear now we've seen a huge
increase in front Texas budget
commissioner Johansson uh
tackled the director on the way it
worked to and dealt with migrants France
Germany
and other countries
want to accelerate returns but
we know that there are those opposing
our action
we need borders to be
to be put in place to protect uh borders
and we need essential action to be taken
we need to stop being ambiguous and take
action
thank you very much the next speaker is
Salvatore de Mayo one minute Ben yes
thank you very much president welcome
minister
well after all of the comments we've
heard from colleagues it's only uh
natural that I ask myself how long will
this Parliament have to talk
before a council meeting to get a
concrete answer this Parliament has
asked these questions in many different
ways from different political
perspectives but we need a common
European solution
as long as member states put their
National interest before the common
interest we will not find a concrete
pragmatic response
so what we see is that we look on
impotently as waves of migration break
on us and turn into genuine emergencies
I hope that the Swedish presidency will
have the strength to get an agreement
that is based on solidarity and the idea
that the Southern and East is Broad and
borders are European borders
and we have to ensure returns take place
but also promote integration in the
social in society and the labor market
we need to ensure that there is the
necessary resources to rapidly examine
Asylum claims we also
need to ensure that ngos take their
share of responsibility to respect
International and national law in search
and rescue operations so I'd like to
wish you the best of luck it's a
difficult job and I hope that you'll be
successful
[Applause]
thank you very much we move now to the
interventions and the the catch AI
procedure I have colleagues to stick to
the allocated time so that I can give
the floor to as many as possible
beginning with stelius Kim paropolis
you've got the floor
problem
is going to be discussed in the council
this is a result of the dramatic
increase of the flows the countries of
reception
such as Greece they have to uh to Bear a
very big load and they have to fulfill
the European and international rules and
obligations and this increases the
pressure on the systems of Asylum and of
reception and the summit of next week
should be the beginning of finding a
real European solution a solution that
first of all will assure a just a
distribution of
responsibility of the member states and
will address the misuse of the of the
human Problems by the traffickers and
we have to find a solution for the
migration there is no any time we can
lose anymore thank you
thank you very much Fernando Lopez
Aguilar you got a farm
third president
since the beginning of Putin's war
against Ukraine
um we have seen
um
under thousands of people who have left
at least four thousand have decided to
stay here permanently and no one has
questionated the European social model
or how we take people in and integrate
them why don't we try to
uh transfer this it's the only effective
way to try to
um avoid
um this the way in which people use a
panic about migrants for elections we
have to transform it into something
positive we need to fight against the
traffickers who are exploiting uh human
beings the sign of a migration pact is
the road map it's an opportunity to
finally demonstrate binding solidarity
and shared responsibility but that's not
all we need to do we need to open up uh
legal channels and humanitarian visas as
well as a European
um
um is rescue at Sea uh programmer that's
the only way we can solve this problem
thank you thank you very much next
speaker
tineka streak
one minute
thank you chair yeah we are generously
hosting refugees from Ukraine and
rightly so but the EU seems to forget
that the refugee is a refugee no matter
the country of origin and most Asylum
seekers in Europe they come from Syria
Afghanistan Iraq turkey
those refugees are pushed back at
Europe's Borders or face huge obstacles
in asking for Asylum and get a proper
reception and what is the EU answer to
these protection gaps
more walls more drones more returns more
funding to Libyan detention centers and
to autocratic regimes like Egypt turkey
and Morocco
deterrence and shifting responsibility
instead of respecting the rights of all
refugees but there is no space for
Selective morality so I urge the
commission and the council can care for
our credibility care for our values
thank you very much next speaker Berta
Kempa
president
Madam Minister ladies and gentlemen
Europe is facing a problem with illegal
migration today I actually this entire
policy so far has gone bankrupt I'm
happy that Madam President Van Der Lyon
is talking about reinforcing borders she
also said that we should fight against
people Smugglers all those who make the
illegal migrants come also create an
illusion among those people back home
and they charge them a lot of money we
also know today that other members
states and their services and the
services of the United States are
talking about this problem being uh
funneled by external forces such as
Belarus and Russia they are behind the
efforts to break out the Eastern borders
of Europe they are trying to destabilize
us that's why we have to reinforce
frontex provide them financing reinforms
border guards and Border Protection and
change our policies at the European
level and the most important issue is
humanitarian assistance in situ at the
location back in their countries that
will help us as well thank you very much
thank you very much next speaker Claire
Dali you've got it
thanks president Europe's population is
aging over the next 30 Years our active
Workforce will decrease by 50 million
without migration we Face enormous
problems to keep our societies going yet
we have the senseless spectacle of
governments all over Europe freaking out
about the pension's time bomb while at
the same time standing over migration
and Asylum policies designed to
violently keep out the very young people
who could defuse that bomb are already
overwhelmed Health Services will sink
altogether without the migration needed
to redress the balance between young and
old our political attitudes to migration
frankly are a form of collective lunacy
at the end of 2021 the share of refugees
in the EU was 0.6 percent compared to
its total population
0.6 it's embarrassing that we spend so
much time on this tiny number of people
this is not a hard problem to deal with
it's actually not a problem at all it's
an opportunity we need safe and legal
Pathways for people who want to come
here stop pushing them back stop sending
them back stop beating them at the
borders stop allowing the opportunists
on the right to set the terms of this
debate let people in let them access
good jobs and let them guarantee in that
a future for Europe
[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much next speaker
for speaking oh sorry I can't
um
the European Union is saying that
we're building bridges rather than walls
indeed
around Europe there are walls being
built
and all kinds of other fortifications my
impression is that we are building a
rich European Fortress here
these days in euros
we have 18 hundreds of walls and fences
that's 12 times the length of the Berlin
Wall 320
000 refugees or migrants it
even illegal there are
0.06 percent of our population in Europe
that 0.06 percent is that such a problem
they can be received they can be
screened whether they can stay here and
then send back rather than being kept in
facilities where they have to spend up
to three years under very difficult
conditions that is the case for example
back in Poland
we all want to enjoy freedom of movement
then why are we saying that migration is
illegal everyone has the right to move
around and no one is illegal as such
thank you very much
[Applause]
next speakers Margarita Marx you have
the floor
thank you very much president Minister
commissioner
now there is a point on the economy at
the European Council and that's on the
European sovereignty fund that is one of
the pillars of the uh new approach to
the uh green deal it's got objectives
including supporting a European
industrial policy that is green
it will ensure that the new rules for
state aid ensure a Level Playing Field
in the single Market
and that should avoid any danger of
fragmentation which is what we have seen
in the recent suspension of the state
aid rules
and at the same time we have to respect
the WTO rules we need a new fund as we
did when we created Next Generation EU
and sure
just a real
attributing funds that are already
available is not enough the EU has to
strengthen its industrial and
technological basis it has to strengthen
people's skills and it has to strengthen
its trade agenda thank you
thank you very much
next speaker Eric McCart
one minute
yeah
thank you president quite honestly I am
at a loss listening to what those on the
right of this house have to say that has
been the case for years it's nothing new
that they suggest building
fences increasing pushbacks
bring people back to the Mediterranean
Shores from which they departed there's
nothing new here we've heard that from
the right of this house for the last 20
years or more
that is what we hear from conservative
governments for some 20 years and yet
nothing is happening is it that perhaps
pulling up the drawbridge is not the
answer that may be the case it may be
that if you suggest bringing people back
to Libya despite it being banned by the
European court of justice well that
doesn't work we have rather dodgy
examples should we not accept that
migration is a fact we it is incumbent
upon us to manage this we shouldn't try
to pursue failed policies we need to
take this Duty seriously tackle the
problem head on not just through the
migration pact because that will not
solve all problems we also need
political will to truly tackle this
problem and that seems to be missing
from a lot of what I've heard today
thank you very much next speaker
dear colleagues the key issue in
managing illegal migrations is the
message that we're sending out to
potential illegal migrants and our
consistency as regards this message
illegal migrations will keep increasing
if our messages do come someone such as
an NGO will already help you to cross
the border illegally if need be if
however our message is we respect the
legislation or borders and there is no
chance you will enter illegally then
illegal migrations will decrease
as regards legal migrations we should
think about the consequences too
immigrants have a very strong identity
and the European mainstream has for
years now working on the
systematic destruction of National
Religious and even sexual identity
and when strong and weak identity meet
the strong identity prevails that is why
it is obvious that the assimilation of
immigrants and European identity with
their strong identity is unrealistic and
the reality on the other hand are no-go
zones and further threats to the
identity and all values stemming from
European Christian tradition thank you
foreign
the European Union may be confronted
soon with a new migration crisis many U
countries have difficulties in fighting
traffickers and organized crimes we also
did not provide all the proper support
to the countries of origin and we have
neighboring countries that transform
migration into a business moreover
according to the commission reports we
also have too many member states that do
not expect what we have already decided
together interestingly enough some of
the leaders that do not respect the
current Provisions are exactly those
that blame the EU on this issue for
example the right-wing Austrian
Chancellor Mr neheimer contradicts the
European commission and is opposing the
accession of Romania into Schengen by
presenting false data on migration while
ignoring his capacity to manage the
situation in Romania after being crossed
by more than 2 million refugees with
thousands remaining in our countries we
do not complain like the populist
leaders we act we help people we also
support the country of origin we are
also investing a lot in Border
Protection but also in offering proper
support refugees but you cannot ignore
that help provided is too little we have
to do more we have to act very precisely
on this issue while in the same time
caring about people thank you
thank you so much next speaker Carlo
Hester
the duration on the European borders is
unfortunately dramatic and it is
starting to look like the big migration
crisis in 2019 thousands of strangers
are illegally entering the EU
it's scandalous to hear from the part of
the left here in the European Parliament
that they are calling for the
non-respect of our common European
legislation Europe cannot look at this
it has to start acting we need to reach
a new agreement about the new migration
and Asylum system we need an agreement
which will respond to this crisis we
need an agreement which needs solidarity
between the member states because for
too many for too much time the states at
the outer borders of the European Union
have been bearing the biggest brand of
course we have to punish the criminals
who are using uh the fact that we are
not determined and endanger the lives of
millions of people like that we have to
protect the European Union borders
thank you very much next speaker
president minister
in 2016 I was representing my country in
Council the European Council
and we had this issue of migration and
asylum on the agenda and I see things
haven't moved on much then neither on
the agenda nor on the solutions the
heads of state and government are taking
decisions it's a question here of
responsibility towards the citizens of
Europe and also
responsibility to the citizens of
Romania and Bulgaria where
things have been very static when it
comes to Asylum and migration policy I
expect that the Swedish presidency will
work hard on a solution for Bulgarian
and Romanian accession to Schengen they
have the right under the treaty and they
have met the conditions thank you
thank you very much next speaker Mike
Wallace
please
if the EU wants a sustainable solution
in the area of Asylum and migration it
should end all the support to Nato and
the military industrial complex
we need to stop bombing people's homes
we should stop sending arms into
conflict zones
we should pursue a policy of peace and
diplomacy in Ukraine
we should stop impoverishing the people
of the global South with financial
imperialism
the EU must immediately end a systematic
criminalization of Asylum Seekers in
pushbacks and the external the
externalization of the eu's borders now
abolished protects
the EU rightly acted quickly to provide
protection and reception conditions to
millions of ukrainians in a matter of
months under the temporary protection
directive this proves that Humane
treatment of non-ukrainian Asylum
Seekers and refugees from Syria
Afghanistan Libya is absolutely possible
we should welcome people fleeing
persecution our oppression from all
places and not be selective about it
thank you very much next speaker now
Costas mavrid as you come from
thank you very much president
we hope that the council will finally
conclude on
um a mandatory European framework for
legal migration and the protection of
Asylum for all those who need it on the
basis of solidarity and I hope we will
finally also tackle the root causes of
migration however front line member
states shoulder all the burden the
social and economic costs on their own
especially in the Eastern Mediterranean
illegal migration
has an organized institutional
trafficker Smuggler that we can put a
name to it it's erdogan's turkey it
illegally occupies 37 percent of the
territory of Cyprus a member of the EU
and through there it is pushing through
Asylum Seekers and illegal migrants now
let me give you a figure in Cyprus at
the moment more than 10 percent uh is
the figure for Asylum speakers and
illegal migrants if you look at the
German population it would be the
equivalent of 8.5 million people thank
you very much
thank you very much next speaker Milan
burglars
one minute
chairman thank you for the floor
children who are forced to become
migrants and refugees are a particularly
vulnerable category they are subjected
to humiliating treatment they are
frequently abused within the human
trafficking they're often sexually
abused and they have a very negative
impact on their mental health because of
the pushback in 2020 at the EU level
there were five thousand and seven
hundred of pushbacks 17 of them children
and this has a negative impact on all
children
we want the new system to provide new
legal migratory routes respect human
rights and also attribute responsibility
for all irregularities at Borders double
standards should be done away with we
have to respect the rights of children
countries can do a lot we have the
child guarantee system available within
the national plans countries have to pay
special attention to children with
migratory or Refugee background thank
you
thank you very much less speaker Maria
grappini you've got for
eign
commissioner
as you said president the migration
problem needs to be resolved
this goes back in my experience to 2014
we can't go back to where we are we need
clear measures clear policies clear
procedures in which we Define what
illegal migration is I'm a humanist and
a humanist party I want to help any
person who can be helped
but we need to be clear
about what we can do in Europe we need
to
help countries that have experienced
illegal migration but we can't put right
or wrong with another wrong uh
Austria has invoked migration as the
reason for stopping Romania and Bulgaria
that in fact is breaching the rules and
Minister Swedish presidency commissioner
you know Romania very well this isn't
right a regulation adopted by the EU is
applicable to all the member states
member States including Austria
thank you very much we come now to the
conclusion concluding statements
beginning with European commission
commissioner Johanna
[Music]
dear president the minister honorable
members
this debate provided and it was not
really a surprise
almost a full spectrum of use of what
our European approach to migration could
be
presented the important figures candidly
yes irregular calls things up by over 60
percent in 2022 practically innocent
lives continue to be lost no not all of
this arriving I need of protection
of those not in need of protection
indeed too few are returned Asylum
procedures take too long
that is why we continue to push hard for
a common and structural solution and
today's debate showed again
that such a solution is necessarily
complex in terms of legislation we need
to complete the new pact on migration
and Asylum we need more cooperation
between new member states and speedier
domestic procedures we need to further
strengthen our Partnerships with those
certain countries most concerned
including Visa policy trade and
investment cooperation as usual from the
line showed earlier that there is
momentum and concrete Focus we have
proven to be able to respond to certain
demands through the instrumentalization
of persons populous the situation in the
western Balkans and the triggering of
temporary protection for ukrainians over
time we have developed a migration and
Border management toolbox we have strong
agencies and we have improved
coordination
I'm grateful for the clear message of
ambition and support heard from the
Swedish Council presidency all of us are
aware that this is a priority for
Europeans independently from which angle
angel the angle they look at the every
complex challenges of migration we owe
them to keep building a comprehensive
solution which leads us to cover all the
different aspects uphold the law control
borders save lives and provide
opportunities indeed for legal migrants
and our partner countries
thank you very much commissioner to
conclude we give the floor to the
council Mrs Minister osval thank you
madam president honorable members
commissioner thank you for your remarks
and your comments you have raised many
important aspects of migration it is as
many said it's complex and sensitive
issue how we can develop a sustainable
solution in the area of Asylum and
migration
as mentioned by the commissioner
commission president and several of you
we are currently facing large number of
irregular migrants
during the informant meeting for the
Ministers of justice and home Affairs
last week in Stockholm the ministers
discussed the external dimension of
migration
there were interesting discussion
discussions on returns readmission and
external borders it was it is important
that we continue to moving forward of
this work
regarding the pact of migration and
Asylum we are all aware that the
negotiations of The Pact will be
difficult and are difficult and
sensitive and that this will require
time
the negotiations within Council have
been progressing at a very good pace and
much of progress was made last year
as many of you have asked for the
council asks for the council to deliver
yes but I would also like to recall that
the European Parliament also must do its
part to adopt its negotiations mandate
before negotiations on all the files can
be initiated one such case can be on is
on the return directive
since the beginning of the Swedish
presidency workers started on the
legislative text on Asylum and migration
management regulation we are confident
that there is a general willingness
among all the member states to make
progress and agree on system which would
provide solidarity and Elevate the
burden of the effect of member states
and improve the functioning of the
current system including addressing
secondary movements
we recall the what the joint blog met
between agreed between the five rotating
presidency and the European Parliament
forces an agreement on the on all Legacy
Legacy proposals by the end of 2000 to
2024 2019 and 2024 legislature we will
do our best to make this happen
thank you again for the date and the
presidency we convey this to the
European Council
that's listening foreign thank you very
much the discussion is now conclused and
the Voting is going to take place
tomorrow the next item on the agenda
thank you very much commissioner the
next point on the agenda is the report
by Mr Godsey transparency and targeting
of political advertising
and as the first I will give the floor
to the repertoire Mr Godsey
the minister Commissioners ladies and
gentlemen
it is very clear there is too much
manipulation and abuse in our elections
and democracy foreign interfere